good afternoon i'm assistant sheriff laz
chavez and i'm here
to brief you on additional details as we
know them today about the incident
where an officer was shot on sunday july
4th
2021 the date and time of the call
the initial disturbance occurred and was
reported on july 4th
2021 at 0 1 33 hours
0 1 33
the a.m involved in this event is
lyndon truong he's a 28 year old
asian male 5 6
and weighs about 160 pounds
the suspect's weapon in this incident
mr truong used an officer's weapon
a glock 21 45 caliber equipped with a
tactical
light and the investigation revealed
that mr truong fired
one round from the officer's weapon
the charges for mr truong are battery
with a deadly weapon
with substantial bodily harm
with deadly weapon on a first responder
resisting a public officer with a
firearm and discharging a firearm
within a structure the details of the
shooting are as follows
on sunday july 4th 2021
at approximately 1 33 a.m special events
officers were working
a concert when they saw an asian male
later identified
security officer
officers gave chase and attempted to
take him
into custody during the custody phase mr
truong was not compliant
and the officer struggled with him in
order to get handcuffs
on his wrist he was ultimately
successfully handcuffed
mr truong continued to resist the
officers and became more aggressive
towards them
as he was being escorted to the security
holding cell
the escorting officers were joined by
other officers as
the mr
draws inside the elevator while an
officer tried
the handcuffs that were on his wrists
while this is happening mr
tran
that is
the firearm was secured in a duty weapon
i'm sorry with security duty holster
that was mounted on the officer's duty
belt
mr truong was able to insert one
with a firearm it should be noted that
the firearm was never removed
from the holster
large striking one of the officer's legs
a second later i'm sorry a second
officer received bullet fragments
to his ankle who was standing next to
the first officer
no other officers fired their weapons
nor
deployed any other weapons during this
incident several officers gained control
of mr truong and held him down
until medical arrived both officers were
treated for non-life-threatening
injuries at umc trauma
they were later released from the
hospital
and that's the question i mean there's
any questions
that's all the information that i have
at this point yes
is that a mental health condition was he
injured or what is specifically is he
being treated for at umc and when is he
expected to be released
he's still at umc as far as the
condition i'm not able to
go into that but his behavior was
erratic that night and medical personnel
umc have determined that
he needs to stay at the hospital a while
longer
okay
was he still in the handcuffs when he
you when he reached
yes his hands were around the holster
and in fact i'll show you some video
here
and you'll all get an opportunity to
review that this is the second time
recently that a
officer has been disarmed um is there
any preparations or changes that will be
going in part
metro we are looking at policy and we
are looking at procedures
but unfortunately no these two events
are completely different but let me let
me do this first
i might answer some of your questions if
we play this video
just to my left the first video will
just be of them entering the elevator
there's no sound and then later i'll
have some more
okay this next video is from the body
cam and it'll have sound and it is what
happened at the elevator
stop no no relax relax when i tell you
dude just relax for us all right relax
we're not trying to hurt you relax
you're okay
okay now here is a close-up where you
can actually see mr truong reaching down
with his left hand
and grabbing a hold of the officer's
firearm that was in his holster
okay with that i'll take
more questions um
does he have any prior history of any
behaviors towards officers or does he
have any
just misdemeanors or any felony history
at all
i have no information on that yet no
that we won't know until we get hospital
records so i don't know
i know you said uh pushed an officer
to start off this whole thing do you
know what exactly led up to that
what we uh what we
doing was being apprehended or
being talked to by security and
eventually ran from security which is
when our officers saw that
attempted to stop mr truang he continued
to run and then
cuffed equipment-wise
i mean this is kind of an equipment
issue too on top of everything right
it can very well be an equipment issue i
spent this morning looking at a
number of different holsters and i have
the same concerns that probably everyone
in this room has and we're going to look
at that and make some determinations
of whether or not we need to discontinue
the use of some of these holsters
and then certainly go into training was
mr trung
a concert goer or just in the area
the stadium so i would imagine that he
had we didn't find any other information
saying otherwise
so we'd say that he was inside
all the injury and it uh it looks
substantial to me
but uh he's doing fine he's at home we
spoke with him this afternoon
how about the second officer uh the
other one was shrapnel
to his ankle and yes he's also doing
fine
um just to clarify so the officer who
was trying to adjust the handcuffs was
that the one who was shot
uh if no the the one that was shot was
the officer that was holding on to
mr tuang the officer to the left
the officer to the left on the far left
okay there's no other questions and
thank you very much
and if we have any more we'll get back
with everyone with an update